some focus on those and then it's like
the quiet trauma so we're trying to map
that stuff so like Louisiana and Oregon
are the only two states that have what
we call non-unanimous jury so it only
takes ten of 12 people in the jury to
convict you to life without the
possibility of parole and it's directly
linked integration that when black
people started sitting on juries they
didn't want people of color to sit on
juries and lower the conviction rate
which is crazy that's right and it's
like how do we help people how do we
start lifting that stuff up and talking
about it in simple language so people
came to like okay that's crazy right and
then we have all these people mobilizing
people and I believe that if we shine
the light and tell it in a simple way
that people will like get it and the
last thing I'll say is that we believe
that systems and structures changes
people's behaviors but neighbors change
people's minds and some of this work is
about changing people's minds about
telling a story differently so when
people ask me like when should the
police be able to kill people that's
what the police will say to me like oh
when should the police be able to kill
people can I say like when should the
police be able to kill your child
right and they're like well I don't know
what I'm like well I don't know either
right some of this is telling you a
story in a way that other people can
repeat at their dining room tables like
how do we talk about healthcare in a way
that people can like say over and over
and the police over and over in jails
over and over I think has to be a part
of the work of building a better future
prasanta you know I think that we need
to continue to make sure that the
momentum that we are seeing is going in
the right direction and I do believe
that the status quo and that politics as
usual is not going to be the way to make
sure that we are going into the right
direction I think we need new leaders I
think we need to support new leaders to
be able to get into a variety of
different positions it's been the honor
of my life to serve as the first Latina
Speaker of the House in Colorado and the
only
and to me it is wonderful to be the
first and the only latina speaker in the
country right now but it's also even
that much more important that we build
pathways for different leaders to be
able to get into a variety of roles from
the city hall all the way up to the
White House and to me being inclusive
isn't just about it being politically
correct I truly believe that you get
better policy when you have people in
positions of power with different
backgrounds and experiences so I'm
focusing heavily on recruitment and
lifting others to be able to get into
the right right places to make sure that
those voices are at positions in
positions of power are there structural
things that lawmakers can be doing right
now or there's elections coming up next
year after the elections that help kind
of prepare the ground for getting new
kinds of leadership I'm thinking
specifically of gerrymandering right if
you can do something about
gerrymandering in this period then in
the aftertime period you might have an
easier time electing people changing
policy or we have a redistricting and
reapportionment process it's coming up
in Colorado and we'll see this across
the country as well it is so important
that we have competitive districts where
people have a real opportunity to be
able to run and to be able to win I
think there's several legal battles that
are taking place right now and I know
that different states are looking at
fair processes and so that is something
for people to be paying attention to in
your particular state as some of those
proposals come up to see what will
actually lead to a fair and balanced
process and I think it's in addition to
that and we definitely know what
gerrymandering has done to the state of
Texas we've had a congressional
delegation that doesn't anywhere in here
I mean you know this Russian resident
like it doesn't reflect the diversity of
this state but it's also voting rights
and I know that's something that I feel
like has been somewhat sort of this a
little bit esoteric it's been sort of
moral litigation strategy I think it has
to be a grassroots mobilization strategy
that the denying of people the right to
vote for a whole host of reasons and to
raise mention them is
just we can't have a true democracy if
people actually can't vote obviously and
then I do think we have to rehabilitate
the idea of voting that it actually
makes a difference and that's one of my
biggest concerns is that you know people
get so discouraged because their vote
didn't count or they vote literally they
were denied denied the right to vote and
I think the mobilization has been
fantastic I mean as I say like marching
you know the women's marches that was
like fantastic that was one of the most
exciting moments for anyone to see you
know literally millions of people going
to tell hall meetings thousands of
people calling Congress but none of
that's going to matter unless we
actually get people to go vote and
changes in office and I think it's I
mean we talk a lot about I just on my
own little example of just dealing with
reproductive healthcare and trying to
explain to men in Congress about how it
all works and it's just I mean I just I
think we had if we had more members of
Congress who could get pregnant we would
not be fighting about birth control and
Planned Parenthood anywhere
sure so I mean I want I want all this
how do we get this stuff and the the
answer is look our political system is
not responsive to the people right now
it is not producing policies the
majority of people want the exciting
thing about this incredibly dark time is
this silver lining that more people have
union got engaged in the process to sale
said earlier people feel like they're
under attack by this administration or
the policies that are coming out every
day doesn't that I mean does that burn
them out we get this question a ton what
we hear is that's not the source of
burnout the source of burnout is you
give up your Thursday night you go to a
local meeting and some guy talks on for
like 45 minutes or there's no agenda you
don't accomplish anything you feel like
you're not doing anything productive so
I think something that is lacking in the
progressive space right now is a
community level progressive
infrastructure that can mobilize people
but it's not just mobilizing people it's
building up local leadership for the
long term from that flows our
progressive policy wins from that flows
our electoral wins without that we're
gonna keep on banging our head against
the wall wondering why do we have all
these dumb policies that are only
responsive to the rich people in
corporations I just add one tunings one
isn't what the voting is that we also
have to figure out how to talk about
voting is not the how to talk about
voting is one way to build power not the
only way to build power and I think
about like you know I remember being in
the White House and Obama was like to
read people need to vote and I'm like
yeah I voted my entire life I still got
tear gas arrested pepper spray be like
all those things happen and voting
wasn't the thing that like stopped those
from happening right and I understand
that like standing the street was super
important voting is also really
important like going to City Council is
really important and sometimes I've seen
a generation sort of above me or like
the Obama sort of team the Hillary world
those people talk about voting is like
if you vote it will get free and it's
like I'm go to my entire life that's
right so I think that like that has to
be one and the second is as we talk
about pressure politics that we that we
never forget sort of equity work as a
primary focus that like while I'm
heartened by the enthusiasm these people
were not with us when we were getting
beat in the street in 2014 right
so life it is it is easier to mobilize
around the Muslim being because it is so
obviously wild and we would say is like
my price would be alive too that was
obviously wild to me right there like
the police killed thousands of people
every day or every year that's like Wow
do me right so how do we make sure that
like when he is gone
that this infrastructure actually in
this energy remains around equity work
because people give real gun shy when it
comes to like fighting from marginalized
people poor people but we often mobilize
around some of these easier issues that
consensus builds on we are at the Q&A
portion I will remind everyone again
that if you would like to ask a question
you are there should tweet with the
hashtag asks trip or you can text ask
trib two five one two five four nine
eight four five zero and I have a bunch
of questions here that I have not had a
chance to look at so I'm gonna look
through actually here's one that's
really good
alexis g on twitter asked how do each of
you practice self-care in the midst of
doing resistance work on a daily basis
can take a heavy psychic toll so i'd
like to hear it everyone when everyone
does i don't practice okay you know I
spend time in the mountains when I can
but it is a challenge I mean I think
serving in my role I've been very
grateful to be there I think there's
been time so without a doubt that I felt
like I had to work twice as hard and be
twice as smart to be able to be in a
leadership position like I'm in so I'm
working on the balance issue so if
anybody has some ideas that South
Carroll of to hear your recommendations
I do I build them as I said of IVA
didn't there is a fatigue setting in
with people that like people have been
working and working and I and I while I
think some of it is like the lack of
infrastructure I do you think some of it
is like well how long can we how long
can everything be like a four alarm fire
right like every day every day it's like
oh that's bad like that's even worse
you're like I don't know
I think that takes a lot of energy and I
do you think there's a fatigue coming I
would say with myself that like just
being alone in a room with four walls
normally can like help me reset that is
like a centering thing for me but I know
a lot of people who need to like be
around other people go to beach is that
sort of thing but for me it's like four
walls and like just me and I'm doing
yeah this is a tough question so I
recommend anybody who's setting out a
new venture also well actually this
doesn't work for everybody my spouse is
also our co-executive director and that
actually makes it a lot easier it does
mean that basically we don't talk about
anything but indivisible and work so
that's not really self-care ii guess a
lot of my my thoughts here so a related
question comes from Heidi he is asking
on Twitter when your effort to start to
feel feudal when you doubt you're making
an impact what keeps you inspired what
keeps you going so I think that's a
really good question
Heidi and I do think sometimes because
this is gonna be a long haul and it has
been a long haul for a lot of folks it's
just sometimes you just have to get off
the field and I think that's okay we
shouldn't you know she recognized that
to me at least in this last year as I
felt like after they after this election
of 45 that it was just going to be you
know a lot of folks are gonna lose
health care just everyday that I can get
up and we can keep the doors open at
Planned Parenthood which is just one my
small piece of the world I know I did
the math and I figured out 8118 people
got health care that day and those may
be people who otherwise wouldn't
wouldn't get health care and sometimes
you just have to like break it down into
little pieces like that and that has
really helped me keep going and I
figured that you know every day we have
stopped this administration from rolling
back the progress we've made on health
care
millions of people of Kelter kept their
health care coverage and that's that's
worth getting up every morning for I
think
I think for me it's results I mean I
think we've had a lot of very
destructive pieces of legislation that
have come forward in Colorado all bills
that got a fair hearing but respectfully
died and I think they're the times that
have been most motivating to me is when
we're able to thread the needle and find
common ground without sacrificing our
values without Lewton without people
losing their access to health care
without doing those things and I'm still
a believer that there is more that binds
the human experience together than will
ever divide us and so for me it's always
trying to find where are there's those
points of common ground so that we can
do what is right for the people that
have elected us this last legislative
session that governor Hickenlooper said
it was the most productive one he's seen
during the time he's been governor and
we really worked to try and think about
the issues that people deal with every
single day we made major investments in
transportation and education but how do
we bring people together to drive the
right agenda forward
but that said never being willing not
never not being willing to stand up on a
tax as it relates to racism sexism some
of our our values that we cherish so
much and I don't think that those two
goals need to be mutually exclusive I
think we can actually do both I would
say I'm reminded that we are born wolf
but something wakes us up and for so
many people it was like a tweet or a
Facebook post or a Google Doc or
something that like helped them see that
they had power that they didn't know
they had when I think about what it
means to empower people is that none of
us can give you power like we're not God
what we can do is like help you unlock
the power that you already have and I
feel like in three years I've seen
people every day like find the power
they didn't think they had and that
gives me hope I think about local
activists here who are like fighting to
change the police shooting contract in
Austin which is not a good contract by
the way one of the worst in the
countries so it's like you see people
like find a part of the pie and they
start to fight and like we've all said
is that that's how we win it's like
these successive little acts like
build-up to be a ripple effect and I do
think that like Cisco said about like
claiming the woman you get it somebody
asked me recently like should we be
celebrating them on
it's coming down and it's like I do
think that symbols of hate and power
hate we shouldn't celebrate those things
but when we think about what it means to
fight and when our generation hasn't
really seen like a fight start and then
get a win like we've not really lived
through that before so you think about
the monuments for so many people where
the first thing that they like Mark's
City Hall they like this is bad and then
they the monuments are gone right and
like you win once and then you start to
believe that you can actually do
something impactful a lot of people with
health care they like pushed against
health care they didn't think they'd
ever get it they called they march they
shut down the town halls and then all of
a sudden like the building get passed
and like that matters to people and that
matters to the way the energy flows so
those things keep me hopeful every day
absolutely yeah basically at a macro
level look we are insisting I said this
earlier we were eight months into a
unified Conservative government election
which we haven't seen in over a decade
they've been promising to repeal the
Affordable Care Act for seven years it
was the number-one legislative priority
it remains that and it's not getting
done as a result of this crazy thing
people standing up in their communities
that is amazing inspiring that you are
able to change what is possible at the
national level through these relatively
small acts and then the other piece is
exactly what Turay said every time I
talk to group leaders or group members
who haven't really done politics before
they're nurses or school teachers or
their IT technicians but now they are
leading groups now they're running for
local office or they're fighting on the
monuments or they're fighting for docker
they're fighting for whatever is up
right now and they're motivated by just
all of the right things and they're
seeing the fruits of their labor that it
that is inspiring I leave all those
meetings inspired to like good related
questions or just go through these
related questions and one of them from
Zac on Twitter is if Trump is just the
remix to what's been around how do we
ensure that people are still as active
once the oppression is not as over any
anyone can take it that's where our
forbidden or I'll just point to someone
ray
like I said I I'm a little worried that
like it is you think about the thing
with felons I see people all the time
like what's a felony and people who
literally believe that like every felon
killed 15 people that is like how people
think about felons and when you think
that there are places across the country
where people are in jail because they
stolen I found there to jail for 20
years because they saw an iPhone like
people are organized like it's not
popular to organize around that or like
things like drug free school zones right
they're all bad every drug free school
zone is like a nightmare and communities
because what it is is like a de facto
mandatory minimum so if you sell like a
dime bag with a thousand within a
thousand feet of a school in Tennessee
you automatically get like 8 to 12 years
if you said that same dime bag in rural
Tennessee you get like I don't know a
number of days and it's like a wild
thing so I say all that to say that I
think that we'll have to be explicit
about calling out like racial organizing
and like organized around equity so that
wind Trump is gone like people still
focus on it because what the Republicans
are very good at is just like flipping
the phrase they the left we kill
ourselves over like the tag lines and
like the words the right will sacrifice
everything to keep the ideology so the
KKK to the white Citizens Council to the
alt-right is the same idea they like
sacrifice all the words they'll like
they'll swap out the words whenever they
want but they will keep the idea
consistent and sometimes we sort of get
in this box for like people aren't
reparations you've become like a bad
word for people so people just don't
even talk about the idea anymore you're
like no we probably should correct for
like you know the centuries of inequity
very like we probably should do
something about that like all these
black kids that can't read aren't dumb
like they didn't like try that's like
it's what happens when like you don't
come from a legacy of reading you know
I'm a third generation reader I'm gonna
durjan reach to my family who can read
and comprehend text my great-grandmother
could sign her name that is wild right
and to not name that and correct for
that means that we are failing as
organizers and I and the only way that I
can think about how to make sure that we
keep talking about it and we make sure
that people who this is not their lived
reality have proximity to the issues
because I'll tell you I take people to a
jail and they see it for the first time
and you're like I get it right they're
like people actually don't live in cells
like you've seen on TV they live in like
these rooms as big as this in dorms of
like bunk beds it's like four hundred
and five hundred people and you're like
this is [ __ ] everybody out that's what
like when people come out of here
they're like let them all out because
this is like a WoW and like how do we
make sure that our best organizers like
have real proximity to the issue so this
becomes personal for them and they
become implicated in it regardless of
who's in the White House well and I
think it's important I mean dragged it's
just that was beautiful and I think the
thing is if we are if we're satisfied
with just an electing forty five then
we're not fighting for the right things
and because it really is about building
a country of equity and justice and I
just think it's important to recognize
that for some of us we fought during the
Obama administration this was not like I
mean you used some examples yourself I
mean we had to fight to get birth
control coverage for women and it was
not easy and it wasn't because every
just said oh that's a great idea and now
we have 57 million women in this country
are getting birth control and no cost
because we fought for it and finally
folks caved and so I just think it's
really important to remember that we're
not fighting about who's in the White
House we're fighting about ideals that
transcend transcend any administration
and I think the exciting thing again is
we're investing in a whole generation of
new organizers and their their ideals
are gonna be much higher than even those
of us on this to on this on this stage
and that to me is what's going to make a
difference beyond being like this this
administration as what you had to end up
sure so I totally agree with everything
that was just said we talked to this guy
Marshall Ganz a lot we've been talking
to for a while he was Cesar Chavez his
organizing director for a couple decades
and now he's a professor of social
change but
he distinguishes between organizing and
mobilizing we're mobilizing is what a
traditional campaign does you get a
group of people to accomplish a thing
you get them to vote for the ballot
initiative or you get them to vote for
the candidate and then afterwards they
energy dissipate and that that's all
well and good for the campaign if you
get your ballot initiative done or you
get your policy passed your candidate
liked it that's fine and it's fine for
the energy to dissipate organizing much
different it's about building up a local
power so that you can mobilize for
individual actions but the importance of
organizing as distinct from mobilizing
is it's more permanent for us the unit
of activism is not the individual
because individual activism wanes people
get new jobs they have kids they move
and that's fine that's natural your
activism might wane but if you have a
group that is building up local power on
a regular basis when a local leader
drops off somebody else is there to pop
up so it's not just all about Trump or
when this is over when next elections
are over but you actually have folks who
are continually investing in their own
communities and in the political
structure sort of on that that topic of
local infrastructure Sarah on Twitter
asks exactly that there have been
multiple mentions of grassroots
infrastructure what can local folks do
to build it if it doesn't exist or if
doesn't seem to exist in the area well I
think the amazing thing is everywhere I
go now I'm sure it's true for the rest
of folks here is that people are just
self-organizing and like my mantra is
like don't wait for instructions this is
not a time that someone's gonna have the
perfect idea they never after of course
after the election and people would come
up to me with these like stricken look
like saying like what what should I do
is if somehow there was like one thing
we could do and take it all away and the
truth is it's not it's going to be a
number of things like I was just in Paul
Ryan's district we have three planned
pair of the health centers in Paul
Ryan's district and they're all at the
risk of shutting down as a result of
this bill and the women there who are
patients were saying like where are we
supposed to go so in fact they had
organized I was in Kenosha Wisconsin
they've organized forward Kenosha and
they have like 1,300 members and they're
now running for office right so I think
it's like everywhere yeah like let's
work for pennies
I really think that is the thing is
don't we you really have to just do what
you can do and I mean I think you're
right your own point is right
who knows what's the final thing that's
going to tip the balance on any one of
these issues but we can't wait till we
figure that out and it's it and who
knows what it was it took John McCain
over the you know over the line to vote
against this health care bill but those
are the kinds of things we can't know we
just have to I really do think we have
to keep moving
don't do the evidence I think pick your
passion because it's so easy to fight
for so many different issues and picking
your passion can be very very helpful to
focusing in on what you want to
accomplish and I have to give a plug for
some of the state legislators and local
leaders at the city level you know get
involved with a campaign with somebody
who you believe is going to fight for
the right values a lot of the races that
we work on not only in Colorado but
across the country you know it's a
couple hundred votes it's 50 votes that
sometimes can make a big difference in
terms of who has power and who does not
and so getting involved making the calls
you know knocking on doors organizing
your community you can actually make a
really big difference when we think
about the black lives matter movement
this broad sort of movement that has
spawned over the past three years is
that people look back at Ferguson and
it's interesting people forget that we
were in the street for 400 days at the
beginning people forget that as a legal
to stand still and in August September
and October that we stood still for more
than five seconds we were immediately
arrested and I say that because we were
able to sustain being in the street for
so long without there being like an
organization that like made all the
decisions and whatever there was like
this infrastructure that emerged and
like I was a tweeter there were live
streamers there was a bail fund and we
like figured out how to coexist because
we had a common goal but it didn't
require like a traditional organization
in the way that people think about
organizations and I say that because I
think that we're in the space in the
organizing work where the internet might
be my chapter right like where like the
internet actually becomes a way to build
power in a bill connection that doesn't
necessarily require like in person as
much as it used to and I think that
we've seen so many people actually like
find a home on the Internet to organize
in a way that just didn't exist before
and I don't think that'll ever replace
the impro
organizing I think there will always be
something about that but it took our
bodies being in the middle of street
that like it wasn't enough for us to
just tweet about how crazy the police
were like we had to actually show up but
there were so many other people who did
so much work that you never saw and it
didn't require their body to be there in
that moment and I think that this is a
moment we can actually build power
differently when we think about power as
the ability to influence a
decision-making process and we think
about politics as the decision-making
process it's like helping people
understand that they can interact in
both and that we can actually change the
way that people do it director I said
this earlier nobody movements so far has
been made up of folks who just stood up
and did it that is what has been driving
this so if you are waiting for somebody
to come over to you and say this is
actually a crisis stand up it's not
going to happen probably it's been made
by volunteers people who volunteer
themselves you know there are an average
of thirteen indivisible roots in every
single congressional district in the
country I guarantee you if you type in
your zip code you will find one nearby
or you'll find a Planned Parenthood
chapter or you'll find somebody else
who's resisting you can plug into this
but if you've asked yourself what you
would have done in historical fights for
justice and the civil rights or the
rights for voting or anything else the
answer is what you're doing right now so
if the question is how do I get involved
the answer is you just get involved
that's what is making this work right
now we have time for one the last
question and I'm just gonna pull
together a bunch of different questions
around the same topic and that is
basically what are the what are the
limits of resistance and a lot of people
have asked about Amp antiphon an tyfa I
don't really know what the correct
pronunciation is they let people asked
about that and sort of there's
resistance and there's confrontation but
what are the limits to that and what
should the limits be should we be
willing to you know punch a Nazi or is
that going too far explicitly nonviolent
in fact a form an indivisible group you
have to say you are practicing
non-violence so we haven't had
examples of individual groups going out
to communities and and getting violent
if we did there would be a problem they
would be removed from the group that
said you know I think it's it's hard for
me to say to somebody else with their
lived experience in this country isn't
what the appropriate way to respond is
so you couldn't be an indivisible group
and practice violence but I the the fact
of the matter is there are a lot of
folks who are under threat every single
day in this country and far be it for me
to say that is that you've got to follow
my way of resisting yeah I think that I
think that there's some people who
believe that the only way that you can
build power is like I think that there's
a way for you to make change without
necessarily being in a chapter of
anything right there's some people who
will never sit in the basement of a
church on Wednesdays like their life
isn't configured like that but they want
to they want to make a difference and
how do we like build space for them and
I think that there's a part of the
organizing community that hasn't like
embrace it they're like people want to
engage differently so that's one the
second is I think that people some
people are more interested in fighting
than winning that like when the battle
is not like battle royale they like
don't feel like they have a home anymore
I think it's one of the reasons why we
spend 99% of anything we ever do talking
about what the problem is and barely 1%
even theorizing about what solutions
could look like about like imagining
like organizing groups don't spend time
imagining often because people are so
focused on fighting like people's
identity becomes rooted in battle
sometimes and I've seen that happen in
three years and that they get addicted
to like what that looks like whether it
is like visibility or Fame and I get it
because part of being marginalized means
that you live on the margin right and on
the margin you are unheard and unseen so
moments like this people who are
traditionally unheard and unseen get
seen in her for the first time and
people can get more addicted to that
than being free I won't say on this
question of violence it is you know I
don't have to condone it to understand
it right like I get it in the fact that
we call for justice and not revenge is a
testament to the souls of black folk in
marginalized people or anything like
I'm continuously like impress with
people's call for justice in moments
when you have the right to call for
something so different so I don't I get
that like part of building a coalition
means that we agree on the same world
that we that we like agree on a world of
equity and justice but it also means
that we might think about a path getting
there like very differently and I know
that the multitude of tactics is
actually what makes us strong I think we
are now officially out of time so thank
you to the panelists
[Applause]
you
Sunday night on afterwards historian
Craig Shirley on the life and political
career of Newt Gingrich with his book
Citizen Newt the making of a Reagan
conservative he's interviewed by former
Virginia Congressman Tom Davis you know
this was an era before cable television
I mean with cable television today cable
news wasn't fairly know wasn't there it
was before CNN or MSNBC it was just
little pockets of cable here and there
but it's mostly reruns of you know I
Love Lucy Danny Griffith don't like that
is this no talk radio to speak of is
that there's the is the big media and
and c-span and he quickly realizes the
potency of giving special orders every
afternoon giving a five-minute speech
you know because it was then being
carried over cable into you know a
hundred thousand homes around the
country and Dick Armey former
congressman Dick Armey used to used to
rhythm about it and he'd say and ganger
to say you know this is that dick would
you go give an audience to Hollywood
give a speech to a hundred thousand
people and said of course you would well
duh but that's what you're doing with
with c-span with special orders every
afternoon so c-span became I mean he
quickly becomes a cult political leader
and he's getting you know 700 letters a
week from people around the country to
this backbench
you know junior member from Georgia
who's a member of a minority party he's
already achieving a national following
watch afterwards Sunday night at 9:00
p.m. Eastern on c-span two's book TV
Monday on the communicators we
interviewed for cyber researchers
teaching the latest cybersecurity
techniques and artificial intelligence
at the blackhat conference in Las Vegas
Internet of Things is a bit unique even
from another embedded devices like
phones because they're typically used
autonomously so there's no human
interaction with like your thermostat or
maybe an industrial controller and we've
seen some attacks where they're able to
exploit like webcams for example
traditionally hacking was more around
building and making stuff and more
recently I think Society has seen it as
people breaking into systems you know
attacking systems in no offensive manner
but traditionally it's approaching
problems and solving problems in various
different ways I think now is probably
the most exciting time to start hacking
the wealth of information out there is
unbelievable it takes very little to
hack today you've got YouTube you've got
tutorials 20 years ago there just wasn't
much it was a true wild wild west and
there was just nothing out there but now
this is a really exciting time
artificial intelligence so this is
taking it even one step further we as
the humans don't even have to intervene
anymore with the computer we just give
it people call it raw data just think of
any type of data source we just pass it
over to the Machine and the Machine
magically on its own learns how to make
useful predictions watch the
communicators Monday night at 8:00
Eastern on c-span
2
now a panel of data security and foreign
policy analysts discuss a report
detailing the vulnerabilities of voting
machines and other election equipment
they also examined the broader national
security implications of Russian
attempts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election this is 90 minutes
good afternoon i'm fred camp i'm
president CEO of the atlantic council
and i'm delighted to welcome you RL here
the atlantic council today on behalf of
everyone of the land council on behalf
of any people at england who's pulled
all this together so it's salute to you
for everything you're doing in our cyber
statecraft initiative an e4 for the
launch of this crucially important
report and you know people standing
podiums say things like crucially
important it really is hacking the
election lessons from the DEFCON voting
village here at the atlantic council we
operate under the enduring mission of
working together to secure the future
this is meant seriously here because the
founders of the atlantic council were
there at the creation in fact one of the
people who helped found us was dean
acheson who wrote the book there at the
creation of the international liberal
order we see that order as being under
threat and we see one of the things
that's most under threat in the order we
created is the advance and the
protection and the security of
democracies we believe a stable
prosperous world depends on building and
sustaining democracy and democracy
depends on the sanctity of the vote in
recent years this fundamental core to
our system of government has come under
threat unprecedented assaults in the
United States and Europe are bringing
scrutiny and uncertainty to once
enviable electoral processes we the
Atlantic Council have been doing quite a
bit of work in countering disinformation
both within our Eurasia center and in
our digital forensic research lab some
really cutting-edge work we haven't done
yet work in this area so it's a
particular pleasure and honor to be
associated with this event and the work
behind it in the current geopolitical
climate preserving or in some cases
reinstating public flight faith and the
integrity and security of our elections
is more crucial than ever before this
can only be achieved if we're able to
protect the technologies to protect the
technologies underpinning our democracy
while much of the disguise
over the past 12 months has focused on
the Russian linked information
operations with carefully timed leaks
fake news Facebook ads most recently
recent revelations have made clear how
vulnerable the very technologies we use
to manage our records cast our votes and
tally our results really ours and that's
new we now have alarming evidence of
Russian connected hackers successfully
breaching electronic poll books and
state and local voter data databases in
at least 21 states across the United
States this recently released by the
Department of Homeland Security and you
have to understand how careful DHS is
before it puts out this kind of
information the technical community
including many Atlantic Council experts
have attempted to raise alarm about
these threats for some years this summer
the experts on today's panel and others
concerned about the safety of the vote
teamed up with the world's larger
largest hacker conference DEFCON to host
the first-ever and I underline this
first ever voting machine hacking
village this determined group invited
security researchers to probe two dozen
electronic voting machines many of which
are still in use today the hackers were
able to break into and gain remote
control of the machines in a matter of
minutes these findings from the voting
village are incredibly disconcerting we
have the Atlantic Council applaud the
groundbreaking and tireless work of the
organizers to shed light on these
threats and this unsettling reality we
believe that transparency is about 80
percent of what is needed here because
you have to actually understand and know
the threat in order to get the targets
and others to take care of defending
themselves this is not simply a
cybersecurity issue but one of the most
pressing national security concerns
eating at the bedrock of our democracy
the council's own cyber team is proud to
have supported this critical effort by
taking representatives James Langevin
and will herd to Las Vegas this July the
first sitting congressman
to ever attend the conference and
witness firsthand is voting village
we're honored to continue this
partnership by convening today's
discussion and we look forward to
assisting in the next steps in this
crucially important effort you may have
read in USA Today that a group is coming
together to try to continue to work and
continue the work around this and we're
proud to be part of that before I turn
it over to Jeff Moss for his remarks let
me take a moment to introduce our
panelists Jeff is the founder of two of
the most influential information
security conferences in the world DEFCON
and blackhat and he's a senior fellow
with the Atlantic Council's cyber
statecraft initiative in our Brent
Scowcroft Center on international
security ambassador Douglas lute is the
former US permanent representative to
NATO and serving under President Obama
from 2013 2007 17 prior to this and
after retiring from active duty as
lieutenant general after 35 years of
service he served as the assistant to
the president and deputy national
security as President Obama we have a
bipartisan ethos you've worked in a real
hands-on bipartisan manner John Gilligan
is the chairman of the board at the
Center for the internet security he
served as president of the Shafer
Corporation senior vice president SRA
international and chief information
officer at the US Air Force and
Department of Energy Sherry Ramsey is
senior adviser to the CEO at cyber point
international engaged in strategy
development and planning she's the
former director of the NSA NSA CSS
threat Operations Center that's a that's
a pretty big job and pretty significant
position where she led discovery and
characterization of threats to national
security systems Harry Hearst II is the
founding partner of Nordic innovation
labs and one of the organized and
organizers of the DEFCON
village he has fascinating insights I've
just heard a little bit and outside this
room on this problem that we're talking
about today he's one of the world's
leading authorities in the areas of
election voting security and critical
infrastructure security and as an
ethical hacker famously demonstrated how
certain voting machines could be hacked
ultimately altering voting results our
moderator today is Jake Brown Jake is a
lecturer at the University of Chicago
and CEO of Cambridge Global Advisors and
co-organizer of the DEFCON voting
village Jake also serves a strategic
adviser on cyber security to the
Department of Homeland Security and the
Pentagon so this is a heavyweight group
and we're all looking forward to your
reflections huge thanks for all of you
joining us today and joining us online
and thank you for everything you
contribute this work lastly I encourage
everyone in the audience or watching
online to take place to take part in the
conversation by following at AC
Scowcroft and at voting village DC and
by using the hashtag hashtag ACC sorry
hashtag AC cyber so there's actually two
C's there so hashtag AC cyber and and
now without further delay let me turn
the podium over to Jeff thank you
good afternoon everyone I'm going to
just start with a little bit of a story
to give you some context on on how we
got here and then just a couple of
thoughts on where I think we're going
for those of you curious
we've had electronic voting machines for
a long time and hackers have been
talking about them for a long time I
think Harry's been poking at them for 14
years i DEFCON we had one of our first
speakers talk about this concept of
black box voting machines more than ten
twelve years ago so in the hacking world
it's not new what's new though is the
attention on them and the importance
that they're now playing in our
democracy so so how did we get here I
want to blame this guy Jake blame him
Jake was this national security
coordinator between the White House and
DHS back when I first started the
Homeland Security Advisory Council and
so I got to know Jake and he was really
passionate about voter protection when
he was involved in the Obama campaign
and so maybe last year we're talking and
and Jake still with his voter protection
hat on is saying you know I bet these
machines are just there's there's gotta
be problems with these machines right so
oh yeah there's definitely problems with
these machines I just don't know what
they are but I can tell you there's got
to be problems so I start looking online
and I look for reports and I look for
studies and I look for you know security
analysts tearing these machines apart
and you can't find any you can find a
Everest report from a 2008 you can find
some very controlled reports where the
manufacturers got the researchers to
sign NDA's and do very limited testing
over a couple of days but for a hacker
like that doesn't count like I want to
see the pictures I want to see like the
trials and tribulations of the people
attacking these machines and so I told
them I couldn't really find anything but
I'm sure they're just a disaster
and then maybe a couple more weeks went
by and then he said you know what you
should just just get a bunch of hackers
to tear these things apart it's like
well that's a great idea
but we're not gonna be able to get any
of these from the manufacturers they're
so tightly controlled there's purchase
sale agreements you just you're not
going to get these machines or the
software and but I started looking on
eBay
and sure enough Thank You eBay there are
some to be found all right I mean we
have to hear that Harry's going to hack
into later and so sure enough okay we
could get our hands on some machines and
they're not that expensive because these
things never get updated they've been
around for like a decade so you can get
these things fairly inexpensively and
then this and so I a located some space
we got we've got some people together we
started ordering machines and then I
realized I'm not a voting machine expert
I can tell you about generalized
security problems I can tell you
historically what kind of systems have
had issues but I can't tell you the ins
and outs specifically so my friend Harry
Matt blaze sandy Clark and some others
who have spent more than a decade
looking at these said okay well you get
the machines and you get us the space
and we'll run the village and it was
really fascinating because if you're not
familiar with DEFCON we have about
25,000 people that show up and they that
divides into many different topic areas
but soon as we announce the voting
village
I got state local county election
officials contacting me desperate for
information like I have these machines
and I have no idea what they do I have
these machines and I don't know if I can
trust any of the documentation tell me
you know tell me what you find and so we
would try to get them to come out and
there I have no budget
I can't travel can you just livestream
people attacking the machines I don't
know how much that's going to help you
but we'll write this report and this
will hopefully help you so this report
is a culmination of a lot of things one
it is the first step in trying to change
the narrative as you'll read these
machines were pretty easy to hack
and this flies in the face of the
narrative that's been spun by the
manufacturers which is you have to be an
insider you have to have specific
knowledge of the technology random
people aren't going to be able to just
approach these machines and hack them
you're going to need to spend some time
to study them and understand the context
and I think we open the doors and 35
minutes later one of the machines fell
it turns out that hacking technology is
pretty much hacking technology and if
you look at the history of DEFCON we've
hacked automobiles implantable medical
devices airplanes physical locks access
control systems Internet of Things
devices adult toys ATM machines so
chances are yes we're going to be able
to hack your 10 year old election
machine the difference now is that it
counts now people are paying attention
they weren't paying attention ten years
ago and so the other thing is now it's
not a conversation I think between us
and the state local officials I think
this really needs to be more of a
discussion at a higher more national
security level and I was struck by
something
ambassador Lutz said which was
essentially there's two ways to change a
government the bullet box or the ballot
box and I thought about that for a while
and we spend a lot of money on the
bullet box we have nuclear triads
we have oversight we have testing ranges
we have a large amount of money and
Technology invested in the bullet box
how much do we have in the ballot box
pretty much nothing it was only just
recently classified as critical
infrastructure so they're both I believe
equally important but all of our energy
is in the more exciting bullet box and I
think part of what we're going to say
here is it really needs to also be the
ballot box because this problem is not
going away it's only going to accelerate
so three things made this possible well
first we have a three year DMCA
exception
normally you wouldn't be able to
reverse-engineer these things for
copyright violations and the
manufacturers aggressively use DMCA
takedown notices to prevent researchers
from publishing results or looking at
these machines there was a three year
exception this last year was year to
next year zr3
if we can get that exemption renewed or
in permanent position researchers will
just be able to take apart this
technology and really provide an
independent view of what's going on here
that was not ever possible before and so
once we removed sort of the fear of
litigation and we lined up an impressive
array of lawyers waiting to defend us if
anything happened we felt pretty
confident going the conference that if
anybody was going to sue us we were
gonna have enough resources defend
ourselves and this time with the DMCA
out of the way we would be able to
defend ourselves the second one was a
giant storm that collapsed the roof of a
building where a county was storing all
their voting machines and the insurance
company totaled out all the equipment in
the bin the facility including the
voting machines and the insurance
company owned the voting machines now
there's no purchase and sale agreement
there's no sort of NDA covering this
equipment the insurance company didn't
want it they gave it away to a recycler
an electronics recycler who then now
they have the equipment with no NDA and
no purchase agreement signed so now if
we get our hands on these machines we
can do whatever we want we're not
violating any rules any civil law well
the manufacturer contacted them and said
hey can you please disassemble all the
machines and you know basically take
them out of commission and he said sure
how much do you want to pay me per
machine so we want to pay you zero it's
like well would you like to buy all the
machines back no it's okay well this is
my number call me back anytime you're
willing to you know change your mind and
you just started selling them on eBay
and ladies and gentlemen the tsx voting
machine and last the final ingredient
was that we have this culture of hacking
things and exploring and publishing
results and so is these
three things upcoming DEFCON the storm
and the DMCA made this possible for the
first time and really that's totally
unacceptable we've been using these
machines for more than a decade and this
is the first time we get to actually
look under the hood that doesn't make
any sense as a country like something is
wrong there from a policy standpoint and
we need to really understand what's
going on and how do we fix that because
we can't run our country like this
when's the next storm gonna happen right
so I really want us to think about that
that said I'd like to hand it over to
Jake who's gonna go into a moderated Q&A
session and then when we're done we're
gonna go to the audience and answer any
questions you may have
all right thank you very much I'm just
gonna sit for the Q&A so first off Hari
you you and professor Blais
were the kind of technical leads running
the hacking village vote hacking village
so tell us what did you find
well first of all it was well as the
blissed that every machine we had is
hackable that was not one thing we we
tried vegetable that was already done
instead this was a learning experience
where people can first time sink their
teeth into the machines find the truth
themselves one thing what really
delighted me was how many election
officials came in and hacked the machine
they used to run elections they really
came can i yeah go ahead
the other thing was the speed a lot of
time when we have been doing on one of
the people who have been doing these
Secretary of State Commission studies
one reboot all has been well of course
if you have few weeks you can hack it
first of all if a nation-state will
attack they probably have few weeks to
they don't wake up in them in a hangover
they oh oh they have a election let's do
that now yeah they have time but the as
mentioned DMCA and other regulation and
India's and rules of the
work Rozsival that was other things why
it took long time right now I said we
have less than half an hour when the
first machine had we open the doors at
10:00 if they livin already one team
came to me eleven was supposed to be the
introductory speech at the time first
machine had already fell and at the time
the guy who did that Carsten he said
well I I said can you can we show it can
even make it proof of concept and you
know I I need to go to I want to listen
this speech but I will come back and he
went to have had a reason the speech for
45 minutes came back and wrote a proof
concept at the same time he was from
Denmark so known us there at the same
time during the speech another team who
was from Northern California active
eople book so at the time when the in
deduction speech was over already too
much in her felt this technology is very
old and for a lot of people who were
there they were not even you know born
when a lot of these chips were convenes
considered so one of the things were
immediately today people were calling in
a Twitter asking for a tools in order to
do because they were unprepared a lot of
the current tools actually are not
backwards compatible that much behind
this tool for example became to be one
of the saving of the day cost 15 dollars
made in New York but this is enabling
you to be compatible with the very old
technology some of the findings and I
would just you know there's so many
things but I want to highlight one thing
which is we found vulnerabilities which
have not been studied before because of
the rules of the road of the previous
studies and those vulnerabilities put a
unreasonable stress - not today
non-existing chain-of-custody a device
can be hacked any time during its life
and once you have hacked it it's a
persistent attack and you cannot clean
and this also comes to the supply chain
we found a components made all around
the world assembly is made in all around
the world
thing from China mainland China Taiwan
Philippines Israel you name it there's
components there's elements and we don't
even know the extension of that host
country what is the extension they have
participate in the design and building
of this so it's the chain of custody
while it's when it's already in US and
put in use but it's a supply chain how
that device came to be where it came
from how you make sure and that the
mission machine you get is clean to
start with so those are tough my opening
remarks thank you so chary after
spending a long time at NSA what are
your thoughts on on the the relevance of
especially the supply chain side of this
but but also any of the other findings
that they have okay to follow on with
Harry's comments in the comments that
Jeff and you have made the first thing
you want to do when you kind of look at
this problem is figure out you know
what's the target is it something that
people would be interested in and then
how can what is the concept for how that
target can legitimately be hacked or
accessed you know would it take a year
would it take you know five thousand
people to do this is this something that
we really should worry about or is this
kind of something that yeah it could be
done but not likely to be done and so
and then the last thing we need to talk
about is would anybody be interested in
doing it you know there can be all kinds
of vulnerabilities out there but if no
one's really interested then maybe we
don't spend money and we don't spend
time and effort worrying about this so
let's kind of quickly answer those three
questions when we're talking about this
so obviously the specific target well
the target might be the u.s. democracy
but if you look at the focus target it
would be the voting machines themselves
and so if you if you look at the
companies not that many years ago there
were nineteen twenty more companies
worldwide who made who recognizes making
voting machines and you know who were
big in that space and people would buy
the boat voting machines from them well
in the last few years just by you know a
natural progression of economy and
things that have happened on the global
scale companies have merged companies
have gone out of business today there's
really only three or four big well
recognized companies that that build
these voting machines that we would be
interested in and purchasing and using
for our elections so just by that virtue
we have really focused the target set
it's no longer hundreds or even tens
it's three or four and so that was a
very specific limited target set that
that an adversary would would need to go
after the second thing is to you know
let's kind of look at how could this be
done is there a realistic way to do that
well you know if you look at the voting
machines as well as in fact look at our
laptops look at your cell phones that
many of you are using now watches on our
arms children's toys our refrigerator
what are all missiles airplanes we go on
in fact you talked about a lot of them
that we have already been at DEFCON what
do they all have in common well they all
have in common they're built of Hardware
chips like this one here and there they
run with software and you know what and
I think as you both mentioned in a lot
of ways it's not even specific to the
voting machine it's hardware and it's
software and there's chips that are
manufactured globally because of the
global economy and we don't know where
all the chips come from in fact not many
of them come from the US they come most
of them come from outside of the US
primarily for cost purposes so there is
kind of this natural approach it's hack
the software which has been done for
years but even more so
hackers are starting to look at Hardware
for a number of reasons a couple of them
are Hardware hacks can be more
persistent if you do a software upgrade
the the malware will the the firmware
will stick through that and also often
times we think things are not connected
to the Internet
oftentimes when we think they're not
they really are by the way but in in on
the off-chance they're really not and
somebody wanted to get into this device
and perhaps take data away from it
exfiltrate data they have to find a way
to get it out so if they do a hard kind
of hardware hack a hardware implant
change the firmware change a chip now
they've also just created a path for
them to put the data out
and and I'll say little bit more about
that in just a moment so because of the
global marketplace because the voting
machines as well as many many other
things maybe everything is made of just
hardware and software the concept for
how to do this is actually pretty well
known and and relatively easy as we've
seen so this kind of curve we've created
this opportunity and so now who would
want to do this and who has the
capability to do this well you know we
we can look at a number of nation-states
who have been actually trying to
influence the u.s. elections for years
they've just been doing it in other ways
now we've given them this way to
particularly do that but perhaps there's
other elements as well criminal
criminals terrorist groups many of them
out there are generally accepted I
believe by the community and the know of
having the wherewithal that is the
sophistication the money the wherewithal
to actually pull this off and so you say
okay well you know still it's hard how
would they do that that'd have to do it
one voting machine at a time you know
they're spread all over the country well
you know not really if you go back to
that limited target set they're coming
from four different manufacturers and
really the supply chain is a great kind
of infection vector for them to do that
and even within the supply chain there's
so many opportunities it could be done
with an insider just for money they
could really care less about the u.s. we
just pay them off